in India a two year old little girl is
being held by some as the incarnation of
the hindu goddess lakshmi born with four
arms and four legs lakshmi tattwa bears
a striking resemblance to the goddess of
wealth and fortune
there's really didn't somebody a
Starbuck Apollo
but Lakshmi's extra limbs belong to a
parasitic conjoined twin and doctors
don't see this rare life-threatening
medical anomaly as a blessing
[Music]
dr. Sherin Patel a renowned orthopaedic
surgeon from Bangalore has examined
watch me and hopes to surgically
separate her from her unformed twin
[Applause]
[Music]
initial impression is very doable how
easy or how difficult it is to do it is
a question I'll be able to answer only
later once we are through the
investigations but nothing will happen
unless dr. Patel convinces Lakshmi's
parents to bring her to Bangalore for
tests in the meantime the Tatas and dr.
Patel head to a local fair to celebrate
the holy day of the Goddess Lakshmi once
in the crowd it's clear that the little
girl has a profound effect on the
villagers
[Music]
Lakshmi sits opposite the shrine in
plain view of those who worship her
[Music]
- number llamando five you want the
amiga Rupa Lakshmi is revered by the
villagers but some are wary of what her
future holds
[Music]